Turtle Rock Studios the developer behind
left 4 dead and more recently evolved is
currently hiring for an unannounced new
IP whether you want to work for them or
just want to play the new game it's
potentially exciting news I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update a job
listing for an animation programmer has
been posted by evolve developer Turtle
Rock Studios the job listing teases that
the game will be cutting engine is
coming to next-generation hardware which
is likely a reference to PlayStation 4
and Xbox one Turtle Rock has to further
job ads posted to its careers portal one
for a narrative director and another for
a senior rendering programmer these ads
specifically mentioned ps4 and xbox one
as well as PC the developer is looking
to fill three other positions though
those ads don't mention new IP in
addition to the new IP it is possible
that turtle rock is working on a sequel
to evolve the game shipped 2.5 million
copies and was described by take to
management as a permanent franchise like
Grand Theft Auto and red dead redemption
did you enjoy evolve would you rather
have a sequel or a completely new game
let me know in the comments or come and
find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot
hmm